الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مازال يمنع دخول
المساعدات الى شمال قطاع غزه مما فاقم
معاناه المواطنين في الحصول على المواد
الاساسيه وعلى الطعام وعلى الشراب الاساسي
للاستمرار في الحياه الاف العائلات هنا في
شمال القطاع غزه تعاني من نقص التغذيه ومن
عدم توفر المواد الاساسيه وايضا عدم
القدره على شراء هذه المواد الان الاحتلال
يتعمد مرحله تجويع المواطنين هنا في شمال
قطاع غزه والله هيك شايف وضعنا هيك شايف
الاولاد بقولوا ما بدنا ناكل ققول ما في
اكل بنا بالجوع وبشرب بشربوا ميه
بغسل بغسيل بميه يعني ايش هالحياه
هذه والله العظيم ما عيشه الموت اصلح من
هال العيشه الاولاد يوم ما بدي اكل يوم ما
فيش اكل يوم انا ومعي سبعه انفار والاولاد
بموتوا من الجوع بدهم الد ياكل بقول لهم
يوم ما فيش اكل مرات الله بصحب رغيفه القد
بقت مع خمس استنفار ومرات بينهم بالجوع
ومرات بروحوا يشحد من الجيران ومرات شيء
بعطيهم ششي بعطيه هم يعني مش حياه هذه
ياما والله يا خالتي ما هي حياه اقسم
بالله بنم بتجوع انا والاولاد بسكته يما
يوم بجيب بسكوته حاجه بليمونه بقصره
برتقانه بسكته البلاد اللي بره يقفوا معنا
مش بتفرجوا علينا كل البلاد بتفرجوا علينا
مش طالع بدهم شيء يشفقوا علينا ي يقفوا
معناا يعملوا لنا حل بقول لك عشان فيش
طحين بتجيب علف الدوا وطحن ولحتى الان ما
فيش يا ريت ندور عل لاقيه لو دور عليه
بمشي الحال الحين
مقطوع يا ريت في يا اخويا يا ريت في جبنا
مره ومرتين وبعد هيك انقطع الخيم لما
بتطفح الميه بالغرق هيك بصير حواليني بصير
احمل في الاولاد اناكل فيهم من ه انا
وابوهم والريحه والمغرفه وال يعني بالمره
بالمره
والمجاري صعب والحياه صعبه كثير كثير يعني
حياه يعني عمرنا وصلنا لهذ الحياه يا
اخويا
عظيم امبارح يقول يما جعان يما جعان اقول
ايش اعمل لك رحت شعلت من الجيران ماحدش
رضى يعطيني يت في طحين ي كان الواحد شار
يا ريت فيش بالمره بالمره يا خال والله
العظيم ماتوا الاولاد من الجوا انا عندي
في الدار 35 نفر عيلتي مع ناس اللي هم
غادروا بيوتهم دورهم تدمرت وجايين عندي
مقيمين او نازحين في بيتي مش في السوق
بشوف الا
الاواعي
اللي هو لعب الاولاد
صغار اما الاكل والش فيشهد الله لدرجه انه
طحنا الجمح تبع الحيوانات وطحنا الرز تبع
الموال عشان نعمله
خبز ما ضلش الا نطحن الذره والى ما ذلك
قبل ايام القائمين او اللي هم الناس اللي
كانت حراسه على المساعدات الاحتلال قصفهم
فالاحتلال هو المسؤول عن تجويع وبده ايانا
بدل ما يعد شهداء من القصف نموت من
الجوع الله يكون معين للناس فيش بالنسبه
لشمال قطاع غزه فش اي مقومات للحياه قصف
ودمار وتجويع لالاف المواطنين هنا في شمال
غزه هذا ما ينتهجه الاحتلال بحق الاف
العائلات في هذه المناطق في ظل منع دخول
المساعدات والمواد الاساسيه للاستمرار في
الحياه انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه